The number of people who abstain from vaccinating themselves and their children has increased over the last few years
Listening to their justifications may disappoint you
In this section, we therefore want to list and respond to the most common points of argument, one by one
So we can help you clarify the facts when you encounter someone next time
Why do not I feed my children !?
Point # 1:
Because the vaccines contain MSG, Anti-freeze and formaldehyde as well as aluminum, lead and mercury
True, vaccines contain chemicals
Some vaccines contain mercury, aluminum and formaldehyde. All substances may cause poisoning
But do you know what also causes poisoning?
Water at high doses, even apples and coffee. And anything in fact if it was dealt with excessively
The important thing is not the substance, but the important dose
The doses of these substances and minerals are very few, making them (non) toxic
For example, aluminum is added to make vaccination more effective
Its dose in dose is about one part of 10 milligrams
In contrast, the natural person takes the equivalent of 30 to 50 milligrams in food and drink daily !!
This amount is equivalent to more than one dose every day !!
Although some warn of the presence of mercury
Such as thymerasol, a preservative that is present so that vaccines do not contaminate harmful bacteria
In fact, this substance has been eliminated in most vaccinations given to children since 2001
This was even reassuring parents of children (after rumors spread) and not because it is harmful to the dose in the vaccination
Question # 2: I do not give my children anything but natural
Natural quinoa is better than plant biscuits
It is obvious that the natural thing is better than the factory, do not you agree with me?
Therefore, the best immunity the child gets is natural, without vaccination and accompanying pain
Vaccines enter weakened bacteria into the body, so that the immune system recognizes them and learns to deal with them in the future
It is true that newborns have a natural protection against diseases, because they get antibodies through breast-feeding
And the thousands of germs they have been exposed to since they were born
But vaccinations cover diseases, which children can not be immune to when they are born
Vaccinations do not include all possible diseases
But only diseases that are dangerous
Children are vaccinated at a very young age because this is the most time they are exposed to serious complications of the disease
Question # 3: What about allergies !? My relative tasted her son, and now he has an allergy to nuts!
I do not want my son to be allergic
Beginning in 1997, the question was whether there was a link between vaccines and allergies
The study of 2100 children aged between 5-6 years. The researchers found that in fact vaccinations have the opposite effect, the proportion of people with allergies is lower in both restaurants
Point 4: Originally these diseases are not that bad, why vaccination !?
This is my strong child carrying my genes, not afraid of these diseases. What if measles hit him! What's the worst that can get !?
Over the years, vaccinations have succeeded in our diets from many diseases, to the extent that we no longer realize the seriousness of these diseases because we may not have seen them beforehand
But this is the picture of those diseases without vaccinations
In 1967, smallpox caused millions of deaths
In 1980, the number of smallpox deaths was zero
Before polio vaccination
Between 13 and 20 thousand cases in America alone were infected each year
These children needed crutches or chairs to support them in their movement and in some cases of devices that help them to breathe!
Between 1964 and 1965
Before the presence of measles vaccination, received 2,100 fetal deaths and 11,250 abortions, in addition to 20,000 children infected with the disease,
Half of them were tainted, more than 3,000 were blind, and 1,800 were mentally retarded
As for measles, and prior to the vaccination, the disease was affecting almost all the population of the United States, because the disease has a tremendous ability to move and infection
WHO estimates that because of vaccination against it, we have managed to avoid more than 20 million deaths from measles - around the world - in the last 16 years
Point # 5: Well, but you have not touched on ... Autism !!
Most groups that warn against vaccination are associated with this paper, published in the late 1990s that claimed a link between vaccination and autism
The proposed link was that the MMR vaccine caused gastrointestinal dysfunction, which in turn caused the emergence of autism in children
A few years later, it was discovered that the study was fabricated in the cases in which it was written. The results were denied by 25 large studies that tried to find this link and did not find it
In addition, 10 out of 13 authors of the first study announced that they would like to withdraw their names, since they no longer supported the study result
While parents' fear of their children can be understood, the link between vaccination and autism has no scientific basis !!
Point # 6: There should be a common choice between parents and the state
Question # 6: No one knows what benefits their children more than you (parents). This option will only affect you and your children
In fact, this is not true. Vaccinations are not only about protecting your children, but also protecting other people.
A child who is not ill does not transmit infection to those around him, and those who may be less able to cope with the disease, such as the elderly and newborn babies
Or those who can not take the vaccination because of their health status.
Such as patients treated with chemotherapy
The more people are vaccinated, the more difficult the bacteria will spread in society
This concept is called "community immunity" or "herd immunity"
For those who can not cope with the disease, community immunity is the only way to protect them
Point 7: Intelligence agencies, pharmaceutical companies, factories .. They all conspire against us and we should not trust them! And witness how many drugs were withdrawn from the market. The goal won them!
Confirmation Drug companies win the sale of vaccines
The size of the vaccine market is estimated at $ 24 billion. Very large number!
But if you want to talk about real profit! This is a study of the profits from the sale of vaccines in the United States between 1994 and 2013
Vaccinations provided pharmaceutical companies $ 295 billion during these years. And provided the state and society $ 138,000 billion !! Of the cost of treating these diseases.
True, there are medicines that have been withdrawn from the market after the emergence of side effects were not known before
However, vaccinations remain among the most highly regulated and continuous pharmaceutical products. Because they are given to healthy people (as a preventive rather than therapeutic measure), most of them children
Vaccinations undergo several stages of testing, to determine the most appropriate dose, to be the safest and most effective
In Canada and the United States, the vaccine may take between 10 and 25 years of testing before obtaining a permit to issue
Even after it has been released for use
There is continued control over it.
The incidence of severe side effects of vaccination, such as the MMR vaccine, is close to 1 in every million restaurants. Less than one of us gets hit by lightning from the sky